zwei Fragen an dich die erste glaubst du
die Abrechnung des Lied war wichtig und
der Gangster mit Tourette nach den zwei
soft teelern Halloween und ich bin
jemand brauche das Geld dafür dass es
damit geschafft und die zweite Frage ist
was ist deine Meinung dass meine deine
Meinung nach das beste Lied was wir
gemacht hast meine Meinung nach das ist
der Part auf bei wenn der da überhaupt
Geist überhaupt
also junger Mann erstmal wundert mich
dass du überhaupt ich bin jung und
brauche das Geld und hallo wie
mitbekommen hast weil du siehst sehr
jung aus da musst du ja richtig junge
noch gewesen sein und Abrechnungen war
damals der richtige step außer
vielleicht dass ich nicht rausgebracht
habe damals war ich irgendwie auf dem
Film nee es geht um die Ehre und bla
hätte ich vielleicht lieber als Single
gemacht hätte ich ja noch wenigstens ein
bisschen Kohle davon bekommen es war der
richtige step und ich bin halt kein
aggressiver mensch ich bin auch keiner
der von alleine Leute ist aber
Abrechnung ist ja nur eine Art Rache
fällt zu gewesen weil es mir bis hier
stand weil alle mich gedisst hatten in
der Zeit und ich habe mich einfach nur
gewehrt und von daher
das ist auch mein Rad wenn für andere
Rapper vielleicht sollte man nicht
direkt von alleine irgendwelche Leute
wissen die man nicht persönlich kennt
aber wenn die Leute das unbedingt so
wollen dann muss man auch seine Rapper
ihre verteidigen so ist halt das
Geschäft